About 18 months ago, I made
a trip up to Eugene, Oregon,
back when we would do such things.
I went to go see a guy
named Mark Frohnmayer.
He's the founder and CEO
of a company called Arcimoto,
which makes this very cool
and kind of different electric vehicle.
They call it a Fun Utility Vehicle, a FUV.
It's super fun to drive,
and I took it all around Eugene.
The company, after this
really long struggle,
had started to hit its stride.
Its manufacturing plant
was up and running.
They knocked out the first 100 vehicles
and started delivering
them all up and down
the West Coast of the United States.
And then, of course, the
coronavirus came along,
and slowed everything down for them.
But if there's a bright
spot in any of this,
at least for Arcimoto,
it's that their vehicles
have turned out to be really
useful during the pandemic
and maybe to have opened
up some new opportunities
for the company.
And so with that, let
us head up to Eugene,
and Mark's house, and
check in on Arcimoto.
Ah-ha, I get to take a tour of your house.
Yup, right?
That's one of the rare
perks of doing this.
We cleaned up the kitchen just for you.
This is the one you've
had since the start?
This is VIN number zero.
I don't know if you can read that.
I don't know if this is too awkward,
but can you sort of
flip your screen around,
so that somebody who's never seen
one of these before can
take a peak at the console?
So you got the, it's a fairly bare bones
screen shows your state of charge.
The phone, you put your,
so if you want navigation,
you just have it on your phone right here
in the middle of the handlebars,
and then all your controls
are on your hands.
So you've got, it really,
the vehicle is, I think, that combination
of having something that's
really, really fun to drive,
and is practical for daily trips,
and at the same time makes
a meaningful statement
about sustainability.
I dig the red, man.
It's a sweet ride.
But I've got to assume you
guys have been struggling
a little bit to get some of the new ones
that you've made out to customers.
Well, we've been doing some kind of crazy
California road trips.
We, the one way we figured
out we could do deliveries,
just for some very key ones,
was we got a motor home.
We're loading up the very first delivery
outside of Arcimoto for
commercial purposes.
We've enclosed our COVID
bubble on the road.
One nice thing about driving in California
in the middle of the pandemic is
it's the very first time I've ever seen
Google Maps be all green.
It is one of the only nice
things to come out of this.
Get all those gas cars off the road!
Hey, Mark, what's up, buddy?
Just wanted to let you
know how much I am enjoying
my amazing FUV Arcimoto.
It is an absolute blast.
How did this stuff with
Mark Wahlberg even come up?
He was actually, he's a business partner
of one of our key investors.
He, you know, he used to ride motorcycles,
but then has kids,
and decided that was not a wise idea.
So the last time I saw you in person,
it was probably like 18 months ago,
and you guys have been
on this long journey.
You'd finally got the
factory up and running
and hit your stride.
You know, what's been the story
of the last 18 months for Arcimoto?
We've now been in production
for a little bit less than a year,
and we've put more than 100
production FUVs on the road.
We have launched our pilots
of the Rapid Responder,
which is our vehicle
for emergency services,
law enforcement, campus
security, and the Deliverator,
which is our vehicle
for last mile delivery.
We put those pilots on the road in March,
and then of course,
we're having this
discussion from our houses,
because we're in the middle of a pandemic.
And that has been, you know,
if you think of the production hell
of beginning the scaling process,
and then add in a global pandemic
that has disrupted supply chains,
made our own manufacturing processes,
we've really had to rethink
how we space people out
within the facility.
All of that's been going
on at the same time
that I think our, the
vehicles that we're building
have become, if anything, more relevant
to the world that we're facing.
What's been your personal
experience through the pandemic?
Because I would think it's got
to be incredibly frustrating.
You get the company to this good point,
you get the manufacturing line humming,
the customers are starting
to get their deliveries,
and then this crisis sets in.
How have you coped with that?
I think the frustrating part for me
is just that we have a lot of customers
who've been waiting for a very long time
to get their Arcimotos,
and we've had to, you know,
hold off on delivering them,
and finishing them, and so on.
If anything, if this venture
has taught me anything,
it is some measure of patience.
You know, I've been at
it for almost 13 years.
And so, while that has been a frustration,
I think the sort of silver lining of it,
at least for the company,
is to have a chance to really focus
on what it takes to get to scale.
And that's important for us, really,
well, for every reason.
But primarily, if we
actually want to succeed
in our mission, which is
to make a meaningful impact
on climate change and
transportation emissions,
we've got to make it
a lot of these things.
We're shooting for a production
rate of 50,000 vehicles
a year in 24 months.
That's what takes us from the
realm of sort of a boutique,
niche vehicle provider to really providing
a mass market solution.
And so, taking the time to figure that out
while the world is sort of shut down
is a good use of time.
One of the crazier things
or the pandemic has been
that the stock market's been going up.
Tesla, in particular, has
basically been going to the moon,
and its stock is sort of
borderline ridiculous right now.
The bull market and Tesla,
it's real, and it's spectacular.
It's gone from $361 to almost 1,800.
Tesla could really be stock of the month
and stock of the year.
You have to kind of decide for yourself
whether this is rational or not,
but without doubt, the
rise of Tesla has had
this knock-on effect of making
all the electric vehicle
makers' stocks shoot up as well.
And I was just kind of curious
what you make of all this.
Almost every, so if you
look at the basket of stocks
that we're in, everyone
from NIO to Nikola to SOLO
to Workhorse, they've all just, you know,
gone right up the hockey stick.
And I think that is
indicative of a few things.
One is that this is the first time
for some people in their lifetimes
where they've seen what
clean skies look like.
And the electric vehicle is
what gets us there from a
transportation standpoint.
And I think also the ideas around
how we're gonna transport
ourselves have changed.
You know, when's the next time you plan
to jump on a plane?
When's the next time you plan,
people are are working from home.
They're, so your need to
commute long distance,
your need to fly long distance,
has gone away largely.
And instead, it's all about
how can I enjoy my local area,
my local community, get
to the grocery store,
go out in the country
for a ride, or whatever.
I think if the pandemic, if
I had one takeaway from it,
it is that it, for me,
it fundamentally dispelled the notion
that people can't change.
Everything changed in the
span of a very short period
of time once people realized
that there was a grave threat.
And what, that actually
really gives me hope
that when people see the enormity
of the threat posed by climate change,
that we will begin making the big steps
that we need to make together,
in order to address the problem.
You're a busy guy, and so, you know,
very busy, in addition to all
the electric vehicle work.
I mean, you've been working on a new
sort of voting system
for a while now, right?
So I had a front row seat
to the political process.
I was actually born into my
dad's very first campaign
for the state legislature,
and then he went on to
hold statewide office.
Dad would be a great governor.
Dave Frohnmayer,
a lot of people really like him.
And what became really
clear to me over time
is that we have a super
broken political system.
What I found is that there's
a little bug in how we vote
that leads to the
polarization that we see,
and that bug is that in every election
we're limited to a single choice.
So what STAR Voting aims
to do is fix that bug
by giving an equally-weighted
vote to all the voters.
It shifts the choice from
one choice per office
to actually letting you have an opinion,
a zero to five star opinion,
on every candidate for
a particular office.
I mean, can you give me
just the bare bone basics
on how this works-
Yeah, absolutely.
And what STAR stands for?
So STAR is an acronym,
as it represents the
ubiquitous five star, you know,
zero stars, bad, five stars, good rating
that we're all familiar
with from everything
from apps to Amazon, but the acronym means
Score Then Automatic Runoff.
All the scores get added up.
The two candidates who scored
the most over all the people,
those are the finalists,
and then your vote simply goes
to whichever one of those
two you gave a higher score.
Okay, so if there's like six candidates,
I can go in, if I want, I could do it
just like a regular election
and just give my favorite five,
and leave everyone zero, or I could go in,
give my favorite five, and
then maybe I kind of liked
the policies of two of the other people.
I can actually like give
them like a four star
or a three star, or something in between-
Yeah, you could go five,
four, four, one, zero.
It's totally sort of backward compatible
with how we vote now.
If you're like, "Ah
that's too complicated,"
you just give you one
favorite a five, and move on.
That's a totally valid vote.
But if you have an opinion
about more than one candidate
running, you can express it.
To whatever level of support
you wanna give a candidate,
you can do that.
Where have we seen it in practice so far?
It was used for the very first time
in a statewide political election
here in Oregon this year.
Almost every single person who was able
to get into the system used it.
Voters, when given the opportunity,
to have a more nuanced
viewpoint on the outcome,
actually do use that capability.
And is it better suited for any particular
kind of election, or is this something
you think is universal and
you guys would like to see it
be used in presidential elections?
Dog catcher to president.
Yeah.
But we think it's gonna
bring immediate benefit
at whatever level of government it's used.
And ultimately, the goal is
to heal the political divide
that we face as a people.
Two polarized parties, each
of which are aggregations
of special interests trying
to get to 50% plus one,
because, and that's what pockets
things that should not
be political issues,
like the work to address climate change
should not be a political issue.
Racial justice should
not be a political issue.
But they end up getting loaded
into one or the other party,
where each party sort of has to oppose
the position that the
other party is taking.
We are not a polarized people.
We have a polarizing process
that is driving a wedge
through the country.
And I think it's to our great
peril that that's the case.